et maxime est ce que t'as vu ta eu des
vues sur delphine à un moment ou un jus
des urnes tel film ce n'est pas dit mais
où les pas des villes afin de lui dire
non mais à des données lorsque quelqu'un
qui quitte en couple je respecte le
couple dans sa totalité et moi je vienne
à une question que tout le monde se pose
mine de rien est ce que kelly et toi ça
peut se faire un nom je pense que
l'affairé conclue depuis la guerre du
lait pas croire mais moi j'ai moi j'ai
l'impression
franchement que c'est toi qui as pas
fait les bons choix quoi et qu'à un
moment tu aurais pu la pécho ouais mais
qu'en fait tu as préféré ne pas la pécho
être pas respect non non tu respectes
pas les cultures respectent pas les
célibataires tu respectes quoi respecter
la vie non non non on se l'est dit
l'année dernière
effectivement je me suis peut-être qu'il
y avait des ouvertures avec kelly elle
m'a fait comprendre que très rapidement
que ce n'était pas forcément possible si
la cua jerry kelly kelly d'habitude tu
inventes wakili me parle beaucoup
souffert crédit le bal beaucoup et je
peux te dire ça aurait pu se faire
il n'ya pas confiance en lui et mon
conseil c'est devant donner un émoi dieu
sec km dans le buffet non mais et
confiance en ton sexe mais oui là et
qu'on fait entre ton sexe quelque chose
quelle que soit sa taille 2 mais c'est
vrai c'est vrai ce par contre vous on a
bien confiance en votre monde
c'est vrai moi moi je peux te dire un
truc ce soit mais bien sûr il est il est
minuit vingt scellés nos ventes et bmp
et je pense personnellement et tu sais
que je connais bien les relations
humaines
je pense que tu aurais pu choquer je dis
la vérité je pense maintenant que tu as
laissé passer sa chance
c'est ça hein mais on sait jamais et tu
sais je vais dire n'oublie pas ce que je
vais te dire quand une meuf veux te
pécho une fois non à l'entente des votes
ont pécho une fois ouais tu peux la
pêche aux mille fois quand la thalasso
qu une fois avec une meuf c'est fini mia
vrai ou pas ça vous est déjà arrivé sur
la partie allait trop dégueu mais voilà
ah oui oui mais vous vous n'êtes pas
vexer vous ne pouvez que c'est jamais
sans une certaine fierté
ouais bon alors on va tâcher d aucune
fierté pécho une fois je pécho mille
fois moi alors je veux dire vous la
plupart des gens ici s'en foutent
totalement on vous aime bien comme ça
c'est très aimable amitié c'est le
meilleur refuge des amours impossibles
ça s'arrête c'est quoi ça c'est la
phrase qu'on te dit quand après une
banane goûté tu kiffes une meuf t'a pas
dû forcer la porte de rigueur ça depuis
avant tout le monde parle pour kelly
mais ce qui serait intéressant c'est de
savoir vraiment ton point de vue autre
meuble a déjà dit exactement et même
époque on a quand même passé deux ans
ensemble
il m'a invité juste une fois au resto
s'est inquiété
[Applaudissements]
et en tout quinze jours et la sp qui
soi-disant histoire avec une ex à lui
est en fait il a décrit notre rendez
vous à nous donc si je suis un peu vexé
des schémas un peu traditionnelle sûr
que ça va ou je suis trop vite on a du
mal à partager
alors qu'on les met en chasse et on a
passé la version yahia la semaine
dernière voilà à disneyland
oui alors est ce qu a eue min dans milk
et mickey dominicale gps critiques dans
tac est très sincère
petit à petit problème parce qu'on était
3e dan et à sa cause il alors mais bon
ça va rien dire ça je vais te dire ça
personne ne lit vous avez dormi dans le
même lit ou pas on a fait moitié-moitié
quoi la moitié de la nuit à ce qu'ils
voulaient pas dormir sous scellés la
peur du loup alors il a dormi à nicosie
non juste avec moi la moitié de la nuit
là aussi les grands et vous êtes donc
est ce que tu as pris dans les bras
panon va pas l'aider
on a même fait un barrage du coup ça
entre nous non wii la wii les frères des
soirées cali j'ai une question à vous
poser s'il avait fait petit barrage
pendant la nuit qu'est ce qui se serait
passé s'arrêtera non mais déjà je ne
ferais ça c'est un spectacle ma fille
avait d'autres personnes
alors j'ai pas dit non mais j'ai pas dit
parce qu il était là aussi
car si vous êtes accro bar vous avez
réservé le champ pour 9 personnes
il était dedans
voilà j'en ai dit ok je n'ai pas pu
aller malheureusement pour des raisons
professionnelles secondes
et voilà et donc on attend déjà d'un
créneau dans la somme entre 4 et 5
heures du mat à vous auriez devenir été
filmées ce avait l'air sympa c'est à
dire écoutez vous allez vous en apprenez
comme moi en direct à 0 heures 24 et
donc kelly ma question est simple s'il
avait fait sauter le barrage
qu'est ce qui se serait passé non je dis
pas qu'on aurait payé couché ensemble
mais non ce qui aurait pu avoir un petit
bisou un petit bisou oui bien sûr on
s'en est déjà fait mais non je vous
parle avec la langue
allawi n'ont pas non bah bisous avec la
langue
après ça s'enchaîne vite c'est vrai
c'est comme le pinot
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]